we'll start the show in just a second
but first i want to tell you about
today's
sponsors hydrant is the delicious fruit
drink powder packed with essential
electrolytes for hydration
and it's more cost effective than
expensive sugary sports drinks
to get 25 percent off go to drink
hydrant.com
pacman and use the code pacman steadymd
lets you maintain a meaningful long
lasting relationship with a primary care
physician
who you can meet with anytime over phone
or video chat you don't need insurance
it's only 99 dollars a month with no
other fees or copays visit steadymd.com
pacman to get started blinkist is the
app that helps you become a more
well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
non-fiction book in just 15 minutes
you can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription
by going to blinkist.com david pakman so
donald trump very recently
pardoned his convicted former national
security adviser michael flynn
and flynn is already out there calling
for donald trump to execute a military
coup to retain control of the white
house beyond january
20th despite the fact that it's very
uncontroversially true
that joe biden won the 2020 presidential
election and things have become
so debased that this story is barely
making headlines this is the story of
a former top national security official
who has been convicted and then pardoned
by the president
for crimes related to protecting that
president who
immediately after being pardoned is out
saying declare martial law
and uh effect a military coup to retain
power michael flynn
endorsed a call on twitter for trump to
go absolutely dictatorial this is a call
from a group
called the people the we the people
convention which says donald trump
should invoke martial law
and just have a new election didn't like
the results of the first one we'll do a
new one
martial law is when you impose military
control
over functions normally handled by
civilian government
it's typically something that is done
only in extreme emergencies like really
extenuating circumstances not
he lost and he wanted to win you lost
and you wanted to win is not
a circumstance in which you uh invoke
martial law
now really we have to understand how
dangerous this arc is
michael flynn commits crimes in his role
as
incoming and actual trump national
security adviser
uh he's investigated trump fires him
seems to understand that trump uh that
flynn did the things he's accused of
doing
flynn cooperates with the fbi sort of is
uh convicted but robert mueller
recommends no jail time
michael flynn then recants part of his
cooperating testimony
then trump pardons flynn whose crimes
are related to protecting trump himself
and within days michael flynn former
national security adviser endorses the
idea of donald trump declaring martial
law
and holding a new election willy-nilly
because he didn't like
the results of the election that we had
once again colloquially
speaking what michael flynn is doing is
sedition
sedition is conduct or speech inciting
people to rebel
against the authority of a state or
monarch that's what this former
national security adviser is calling for
here
fresh off of a pardon for crimes
related to protecting donald trump
pardoned by donald trump himself
the guy pardoned by trump for crimes
meant to protect
trump is calling for trump to use the
military
to stay in power despite having lost the
election
understand how absurd that is every
individual by oh and there there's
another layer to this
uh the day before yesterday trump's
press secretary
kelly mcinanny when uh she was asked
about pardons
and with whether trump would pardon
giuliani or his children as he's
reportedly considering
uh kaylee said the only pardon i can
talk about is the one that happened
for three star general michael flynn
now there's something interesting there
when uh
when someone serves in the military they
take
an oath and that oath
doesn't expire when you leave
active service you take an oath when you
enter the military to defend the
constitution of the united states
against all enemies foreign and domestic
the veterans oath doesn't expire
and so on every level it's particularly
ridiculous
that michael flynn is out there saying
invoke martial law
take it put make a new election because
you lost
but the really crazy part is they want
us to believe they are the patriotic
ones by doing this
even though what they are doing is the
opposite of
you know more properly and sensibly
defined patriotism they are
advocating uh for for the opposite
of patriotism they are they are part of
the domestic threats that they are
as members of the military supposed to
be protecting us against
they believe and certainly claim
that they are the patriotic ones by
doing this this
national nightmare has gone on way too
long
we're down to six and a half weeks but
who knows what they have planned
even after joe biden is inaugurated
scary to think about
uh fox news propagandist sean hannity
is trying to push donald trump even
further on these corrupt pardons
we know that donald trump is already
considering preemptively blanket
pardoning
his attorney rudy giuliani
he's considering pre-emptive pardons for
his son-in-law
jared kushner and three of his children
ivanka don jr and eric but rudy giuliani
on his radio show this week
i'm sorry sean hannity on his radio show
this week suggested
that donald trump should really pardon
himself as well
because everybody's just so unfair and
terrible to trump and they might go
after him when he's out of office take a
listen this is actually from an
interview
that sean hannity does with sydney
powell and it's fascinating that even
sydney powell who's completely deranged
has to say you know self pardons i'm not
so sure about that take a look
unfortunately i'd estimate that five to
ten percent of our prison population
right now
is not guilty but the system did not
work as it should have to exonerate them
and we've got to do a better job of that
not everybody can get a presidential
pardon that well that's a good point and
you know i watched andrew weissman come
out and literally say
oh biden's a.g needs to go after donald
trump
and i'm like the president out the door
needs to pardon his whole family and
himself because they want this witch
hunt to go on in perpetuity
they're so full of rage and insanity
against the president i mean it's
can the president i i assume that the
power of the pardon
uh is absolute and that he should be
able to pardon anybody that he wants to
it is absolute it's in the constitution
i don't know about his authority to
pardon himself
but it should not be necessary and aside
from that the president's going to get
another four years in office to finish
the job he started because the election
fraud we are uncovering
is massive and there were foreign actors
involved in our system
that's actually really funny um even
completely delusional deranged attorney
sydney powell has to mention
you know sean i'm just not totally sure
about trump's ability to pardon himself
uh and and that's actually uh an
important detail now
sydney powell is saying lots of crazy
things here so is sean hannity powell
saying
trump actually won powell's saying
trump's going to get another four years
but she does mention
trump pardoning himself is a question
mark and the new york times had a really
good write-up on this issue
remember that donald trump has claimed
that he can pardon
himself he tweeted back in june of 2018
which seems like a decade ago
quote as has been stated by numerous
legal
scholars i have the absolute right
to pardon myself but why would i do that
when i have done nothing wrong in the
meantime
the never-ending witch-hunt led by 13
very
angry and conflicted democrats continues
into the midterms
trump can pardon his friends and allies
there's no doubt about it
trump can pardon people before they are
even charged a preemptive pardon
is certainly something trump can do
trump cannot protect people from
state charges it is very much
in question however whether a president
can pardon himself or herself
and it's never been attempted now there
are legal opinions on both sides
on the yes side a president can pardon
themselves
the argument is the constitution doesn't
say anything about a limit there
the constitution says nothing about you
can't pardon yourself
the constitution does say if you if a
president is impeached and convicted
they can't pardon themselves from an
impeachment conviction
so the interpretation from some legal
scholars is listen
it's very clear that when there was
meant to be a limit the constitution
mentions the limit
the constitution mentions a president
can't pardon themselves from an
impeachment conviction
so we can infer from that that if
the founders intended a president would
be unable to pardon themselves from
federal crimes it would be mentioned
since it's not mentioned a president can
do it
that's one interpretation okay now on
the other side there are many counters
one counter is the constitution says the
president
can grant a pardon and this is a sort of
linguistic
analysis the word grant
means from the president to someone
else and so the presence of the word
grant
means a president can't pardon
themselves that's one
argument another argument on the the
president can't pardon themselves
side argues that a principle in all
law nationally federally at the state
level there's a principle in law
that you cannot be a judge in your own
case and that a self-pardon
would effectively be the president being
a judge in his or her own case
so the simplest situation as has been
discussed is instead of trump pardoning
himself
and maybe being subject to legal
challenge the simplest
path forward that has been floated is
trump resigns
shortly before uh the end of his term
mike pence
becomes president mike pence pardons
donald trump
uh no doubt about it that would be far
simpler i still
don't think that that is actually going
to happen but it would be interesting to
be wrong on that one and if it
if i am wrong and donald trump does
resign in order for mike pence to
preemptively pardon him uh that will be
one of the biggest
political history stories uh certainly
for decades to come
later on today we are going to talk
about international reaction to the
continued voter fraud claims being made
in the united states and international
reaction
to joe biden continuing to move forward
with his incoming administration
we are also going to talk i got a lot of
emails from people saying david do you
think tucker carlson is the direction
the republican party will go in in 2024
and i have some thoughts about it which
we will discuss a little bit later
and then we also now that the
presidential transition has formally
been started the gsa saying we are
releasing these 7.3 million dollars
in funds to joe biden to officially
start that transition
we are going to address the question of
whether presidential transitions
should even depend on a sitting
president but there's a second layer to
that question which is do they really
even depend on the sitting president
because remember
whether or not the transition funds were
released to joe biden
donald trump stops being president on
january 20th at noon eastern time either
way
so all of those questions and your calls
are upcoming
we've got a great program for you today
let me know what you're following what
you're paying attention to
you can find me on twitter at d pacman
we will take a
very quick break and be back right after
this the david pakman show
at davidpakman.com
[Music]
one of our sponsors is hydrant which is
a delicious fruit drink powder that you
mix
into water for rehydration and they're
giving you
25 off your first order it's made with
four
key electrolytes that the body needs
powerfully supporting your hydration
hydrant tastes great it's made with real
fruit juice it's been a great part of my
daily routine for a while now
keeping myself hydrated puts me in a
better mood
the body needs hydration for basic
energy and focus and hydrant is the
perfect way to rehydrate
especially because it's cost effective
and lower in sugar compared to all of
those popular
sports drinks that are out there you
really have to try it for yourself to
see what i mean
it tastes great they also have a variety
called hydrant immunity packed with
vitamins a
b c and d which is also very much worth
trying
hydrant has a full refund guarantee if
you're not satisfied and you'll get 25
off your first order when you go to
drink hydrant.com pacman
or just enter the code pacman at
checkout i've put the link right
underneath this video
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
all right welcome back to the show let's
go to the phone lines
and hear what's on people's minds today
we
are taking calls via discord
davidpakman.com
slash discord uh let's start today
with uh caleb from atlanta caleb from
atlanta
you are uh you're on the air what's
going on hi david
um i was wondering what your thoughts
are
on the future of i guess political
discourse in this country
it seems like donald trump has really
just made everyone like
very unable to just talk about anything
nowadays
and i was wondering if there's any
recovery from this or
like the future of i guess conservatives
more
generally yeah it's really going to
depend it's going to depend on two
things
the republican party is going to have to
decide whether
the coarsening and debasement of the
discourse that happened under donald
trump whether they want to keep things
that way or not now
if you go back to the george w bush era
there was a hell of a lot of debasing
and
and coarsening of the discourse then but
it was nothing compared to what we saw
under donald trump you know
mocking disabilities and uh i mean
i don't have to give you the full list
you you know it of course um i think
that
the left also has a role to play in the
sense that
the left could make a stronger stand
about
we are just not going to accept some of
this
very base uh way of talking about
politics as valid and we're just not
going to engage in it but i have a i
worry that that could have the backfire
effect that the right will say the left
doesn't want to hear any ideas that are
different than their own
but i think that unfortunately a lot of
this depends on whether the republican
party says
we we have to step up the the level of
debate a little
or whether they you know they if they
perceive that they benefit
from the way donald trump has debased
the discourse then they may continue
they may decide it's good for them
yeah definitely um thank you thanks for
your time
all right caleb i'm going to let you go
sounds like you've got a lot going on
there but i do
very much appreciate you uh calling in
always great to hear from folks all over
let's go to dwayne from buffalo new york
dwayne from buffalo you're on the air
dwayne from buffalo please unmute
yourself you were on the air and you
could be speaking to me right now if
only you unmuted yourself
can you hear me david yes i can hey
how's it going good
good yeah i just wanted to call in and
say you have a
intellectually stimulating show uh
listen to you and kyle kolinsky and yeah
just keep up the good work you really um
you're doing a good job and making
people think very hard about
uh what's going on in society keep it up
i appreciate that so okay so you you
you watch the david pakman show you
listen to kyle what else is in your
media diet so to speak
uh new york times local news
uh unfortunately cnn and msnbc
um sometimes just for fun i'll take a
quick peek at newsmax
okay and uh one american news but i'm
not really uh
obviously i don't listen to that
seriously
and from the standpoint of independent
left-wing media
is there anything else in addition to to
kyle
uh not really um the young turks of
course
okay but i don't really listen to them
as much as i listen to you guys
but i still do my independent research
you know and collaborate things to make
sure
that i'm getting a full like world view
of everything
well it sounds like you're making every
effort to have a well well-rounded
diet is it what what's the scene in
buffalo
in terms of masks and virus guidelines
right now
well our colby cases have been going up
pretty sharply here especially
where i am um but hopefully the
political leaders to get everything
under control you know especially with
the vaccine right around the corner
i'm really looking forward to that um
but you know
you still have occasional people without
mess and stuff when you go to the
grocery store oh are they allowed inside
without masks
uh in some cases interesting interesting
wow
uh all right very good well i i
appreciate hearing from you
yeah you too thanks david all right
there's a dwayne from buffalo coming in
with some uh some nice
some nice praise i would say let's go
next to alex from orange county alex
from orange county you're on the air
um hey david can you hear me yes i can
hey david so um i've been noticing that
there is
a lot of infighting in the left-leaning
spaces
but i've been here a lot of
in-fighting and right-wing spaces such
as
republicans refusing to vote in the
georgia senate election so do you think
there's a lot more
in-fighting in um right-wing spaces but
we don't know about it because we we're
not like
we don't hang out in those spaces or do
you think it's like the same
that's a good question i i think you
know why would it be the same so no i
don't think it's
the same but i think that the nature of
the infighting on the left and the right
tends to be a little different like for
example earlier this week i did a big
segment about how
i think nira tandon is a disastrous
cabinet pick
by joe biden and i explained why and i
made clear that
i don't regret voting for joe biden
obviously the majority of joe biden's
picks are fine and certainly better than
the people donald trump has in power
some might call that infighting but at
no point do i have any doubt about what
the right
thing to do in terms of who to support
is so we have to look at the nature of
the infighting
when you look at what's happening in
georgia where there's a movement to
boycott
the election altogether because
georgia officials aren't taking
seriously enough trump's claims of voter
fraud
that's infighting of the of a degree
that has a very different impact than me
saying hey
i wish biden had picked somebody else so
i think it's less about the quantity
but really looking at the impact of the
infighting or the disagreements
like um i i do and see what you
understand but also
i remember um after the election yeah um
a lot of the democrats are saying like
people like aoc and rhetoric like defund
the police is hurting the democratic
party so
i was like um i was thinking of things
like that you know what i mean
yeah i i i mean listen there are
disagreements over
defund the police but understand that in
the actual
democratic party power brokers
there's very few people who actually
want to defund they really want to
reform when you look at you know
almost all democrats ended up voting for
joe biden so i think that if
what you're talking about is are is
there spirited debate from different
factions the answer is absolutely
is it happening in a way in a way that's
that's destructive
it doesn't really seem to be right now
and if it if it does become that i will
absolutely call it out
okay because um i hope this doesn't
affect the
the midterm elections um in 2022 yeah
sure well yeah we and we we've got time
until that happens but i think your
concern is a reasonable one
okay um thank you so much for taking my
call
my pleasure thank you for calling in
very very much appreciate it
uh we are taking calls via discord at
davidpakman.com
discord let's go to venice italy
and speak to emilio emilio i am
tentatively going to be in venice in 10
months for a wedding if it all goes well
really very much so i'm telling this the
truth
ah perfect i'm glad you can have this
opportunity to visit this beautiful city
i look forward to it
thank you for picking up my call
and i have more like i would like to
tell you that you have a very
beautiful show unfortunately i cannot
support you right now because my income
now is a an intermitting
base because emilia that's okay you're
supporting us
by just calling in and saying nice
things
and i i would like to talk to you to
talk to you about
a friend of mine she was
at the elementary with me yeah
she has her father is american
okay and then she moved back to new york
and uh before the
election she and his father
they moved back to italy and he left the
house the job everything because
she was really scared of all the
situation
about the pandemic and of the
turnout of the election okay and
from there i start looking
more dedicate more time
to all this matter because
i always keep an eye on international
news
but it was really upsetting
all the all this all the thing is
going on in your country
yes unbelievable really that is an
understatement upsetting is an
understatement i agree with you
mm-hmm so thank you for picking mark uh
my call and uh uh have a nice day
oh all right very good all right i i
appreciate it leo yes
and if you if you don't have a um
a flat apartment you can
contact me oh all right maybe i will
stay with you yeah would we have to
share a bed or would i get a sleeping
bag or
no we we
sometimes we rent
a little but a very nice apartment
so if you if you are in if you like
this opportunity and now hold on did you
say little
and very nice or little and not very
nice
no no very very very nice okay all right
emilio i like the sound of that all
right emilio thank you so much
you're welcome you're welcome bye all
right bye emilio from venice italy
what a call that is just wild wild stuff
uh okay let's see um
why don't we go next there's there's
just so many people
itching to get on i guess is the way i
would say it
um and we want to you know take a tour
of different
areas for sure let's go to i i hope i'm
saying this correctly is it sorel
from texas or sarrell
hi david can you hear me yes i can what
what is the origin of that name
what a pleasure it is a combination of
my first and second name
oh okay very nice how are you today
good good but i've been following for a
while and i recently uh
subscribed as well so i thoroughly enjoy
the contents and i want to thank you for
that
thank you basically i just wanted to
make
a a comment on the importance
of education and not only
institutionalized education
but what we're seeing at home i feel
like the
the situation right now in the u.s i
live on the border
so i also get a taste of mexico
and what's going on over there and all
the border issues but
as an educator myself i see this as a
reflection of many years of of neglect
in in awareness and social awareness
right our students right now
have this this sense of um detachment
from the political reality and i feel
like
we you've talked about it a lot recently
so the problem is what do we do with all
these people that
who voted for trump and who who are
um champion champions of of
of these attitudes that cause us so much
grief
and and social um you know destruction
so in a way i just want to make kind of
like a call of the about the importance
of of
making this awareness from home and
starting also
at home because these people are going
to vote in a few years and this is the
circus so governments come and go
but later on you know we're gonna have
to vote again and what are the choices
if we tolerate
all these all these um attitudes if we
normalize
right well that was going to be my
question to you which is
by the time you're as an educator by the
time they get to you is it too late like
it really depends on starting at home
um that's a great question i teach high
school
and and college survey courses yeah so
this kind of
that right time where um
youth um they're distracted with other
things
right and developing a character
but you see the behavior and the
classroom and sometimes
it is this this um microscopic vision of
what we see
in society right right the intolerance
the rudeness
the things that inherently come from
home and and
these are values that have nothing to do
with religion that have nothing to do
with anything but plain moral and being
a good person
well that seems like a big hill to climb
i i i i i think you're completely right
but this is a big task
right and that's why i also think that
sometimes governments um
do not invest enough in education
because it's a long-term investment
yeah if your term is two four or six
years why are you going to
tie up a whole bunch of money and things
you'll never see the benefits of as a
politician
right right very sad very sad just does
that
and thank you so much for the work keep
it up and it's
it's great talking to you thank you so
much really a pleasure uh let's take a
quick break if you're holding on to talk
to me don't go anywhere
because we're going right back to the
calls after this short break
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
if you are anything like me you probably
aren't thrilled with the idea of going
into a doctor's office right now
and thankfully there's a practical and
affordable way
to take control of your health and get
personalized
care from the comfort of your home it's
a service called
steady md they're one of our sponsors
you take a quiz
you get matched with a licensed primary
care physician
who understands your health needs you
have a one-hour video call with your new
doctor
you establish a meaningful relationship
with them and after that
your doctor is available to you anytime
by text phone or video chat this is not
a random doctor on call
each doctor at steady md has a limited
number of patients so they actually have
time
to listen to you you get the personal
attention that you deserve
they can do almost everything an
in-person doctor
can do perform medical evaluations talk
to you about health concerns
send prescriptions to your home or local
pharmacy
and anything they can't do online
they'll quickly set you up with
an in-person provider to do things like
blood tests as an example
you don't need insurance it's only 99
bucks a month with no other fees or
co-pays
there are so many practical advantages
to using steady md for primary care
and it's also so much more affordable
go to steadymd.com pacman to take the
free quiz
see which doctor is right for you i took
their quiz they matched me with a doctor
who specializes in my particular health
needs and situation the doctor they gave
me
is a really perfect fit for me and my
medical needs
there's no risk no commitment to get
started just click the link right
underneath this video
[Music]
welcome back to the david pakman show
okay let's get back to the phones uh via
discord at davidpakman.com
discord and hear from some folks who uh
want to get in
uh let's go next to uh let's go to bart
from california bart from california
what's going on
bart from california you were on but you
must unmute
yourself i'm here how are you david good
how are you
i'm doing i'm doing well we're still in
covid land unfortunately we're in
even in california we're suffering
pretty much but we're safe
right at the moment our family's safe so
that's good good
um i had a you know by the way i love
your show i listen to it every you know
every day
it's just a wonderful show and you know
it's just great intellectual
discussions i'm just really pleased
with the content appreciate thank you
absolutely um mike
my question is about the um about the
electoral college
uh what i'm here here's my premise um
it seems like we're being held hostage
essentially to the electoral college in
a sense that
as uh people leave the midwest you know
the young people leave and go
to perhaps california and new york and
different places that are more you know
progressive uh it's sort of a
distillation process that ends up
causing basically us to be more and more
conservatively
strapped essentially and i just wanted
to get your take on that and what
and which and how can we uh basically
get rid of the electoral college
well so the it's a two-part question
first yes you're absolutely right that
i mean listen any one vote has a
different amount of power
in in one state versus another if you
move as a if you as a democratic
leaning voter if you move from florida
to california
the likelihood that your vote will
impact the election results
has gone down dramatically you still get
one vote on paper right it's one vote
either way
yeah but it's very unlikely that your
vote will make a difference in
california while it was much more likely
it would make a difference you know
you could say north carolina georgia
whatever um so that's absolutely true
and republicans know this republicans
benefit from it republicans
very frequently lose the uh popular vote
and have won
the presidency i believe i saw today
that it's been
in the last eight elections republicans
only got
48 of the popular vote i believe it's
one time or something like i mean it's
crazy
now how do you get rid of the electoral
college i because so many states are run
by republicans and republicans know
they benefit from the electoral college
you're not going to do it via
a constitutional amendment i think the
most direct path
is the national popular vote interstate
compact by which
states can decide to award their
electoral votes not to the winner of
their state but to the winner of the
popular vote
nationally if enough states do that you
have a sort of de facto popular vote and
they have a website and you can
learn a lot more about it that sounds
great that's not that's what i was uh
thinking yeah right it would be very
difficult
and by the way this came this came up
when i was talking to uh when i was
phone banking for biden
uh a person in a lot of ohio was telling
me this
all the young people are leaving ohio
because they just no jobs right so
they're just leaving
well that also you know what's
interesting about that bart is it goes
to the
importance of job creation in those
states because it can
keep people particularly young people
who are more likely
if they enter the workforce in that
state they are more likely to stay
we know young people are more likely to
vote for democrats job creation can be a
big
campaign strategy in practice yeah
actually
with the covet situation a lot of remote
working which i've like hawaii
for example i heard is now trying to
attract people to live there yeah uh
maybe this is a good time to attract
people back to the midwest with uh yeah
you can
you can work remotely right anyway that
perfect idea yeah
um that's that's all i really had i was
just uh just wondering about that
particular topic
um i wish there was a way to get rid of
mitch mcconnell i mean that that person
seems like such an evil man that i just
can't believe
he basically controls the theta of
millions of americans i wish there was a
way to
just tens of millions listen bart i
appreciate the call thank you so much
absolutely have a great day david thank
you all right there's bart from
california
very very strong call let's go to
uh manfred from hong kong manfred from
hong kong you were on the air
hi david can you hear me yes i can
um so i was just wondering
um what the relationship between
and china and u.s would become under
yeah by them i think you're going to see
um a lot of the trade war
aspects dealt with although
you know we have to understand that at
this point
china is likely to sort of want to
negotiate
on the uh removal of tariffs
because what donald trump did is crazy
so i don't you know there are some who
think it will be as simple as joe biden
being sworn in
and then saying to china let's get rid
of all those tariffs
i don't think it's going to be that that
easy and i understand why
uh but i do think that you know joe
biden is someone
who understands much more about china
than donald trump will ever hope to and
i'm hoping for a normalization of
relations
yeah the other question i have is
um throughout the campaign joe biden
always
said that he wants unity and
judging from his cabinet
do you think he achieved that
goal well listen this is a beautiful
question manfred i i really appreciate
it
um joe biden is not going to pick right
wingers
to his cabinet by and large right so
most of the picks i think are very
reasonable people like as an example
janet yellen janet yellen is a left-wing
economist but she is
eminently qualified she's an academic
a scholar she's not going to do anything
crazy
nothing that she would support would be
socialism
she's a very reasonable selection now
uh nira tandon who joe biden selected
the left the the progressive left and
many on the right
dislike nero tandon i think it's the
opposite of unity i think that pick was
a disaster so i think there's a lot of
this and a lot of that with the
selections that joe biden has made so
far
um so overall um what do you think
overall i think that joe biden's
selections
have mostly been of course people on the
left
center left um and as much as one could
expect republicans to be okay with that
they they have not been controversial
selections in any way
oh yeah so thanks for having me
yeah of course so many so you're how
how are things in hong kong right now
um it's been fine
um there are a little bit searched
in cover cases yeah yeah overall it's
been fine
[Music]
we try to get the local cases down to
zero but we just can't do it
got it got it and and have you been
listening to the show watching the show
for a while
yeah um about
august i think since august okay yeah
well manfred i really appreciate it
you're the first caller we've had from
hong kong
yeah thanks for having me all right
manfred from hong kong what a call
what a call we are hearing from folks
in all sorts of different areas let's go
next to
richard from pueblo richard from pueblo
hey man uh do you guys hear me yes i can
cool hello hey dave big fan uh
i have one question and
i'm not sure the other two but they
could be comments or questions but
how's your day the day is going very
well yes
i just heard today that the un just
voted to decriminalize cannabis
i wanted to know your thoughts the u.n
voted to do it what does that mean where
does the u.n have jurisdiction
uh they from what marijuana moment.net
would say
is that they were making the claim that
it it's not a vote that like will change
the world
at the end of the day it's a vote that
will
be like a watershed moment did they vote
to recommend
countries decriminalize is that what
they did
i they use the term international
control
dot dot whatever that means okay
so i wanted to ask you when they say
international control does that mean
like if you have a ship
like a merc ship going from uk
to us and i know it's carrying cannabis
does someone from another country have
the right to stop that
vote or is it like
so here's what happened i just looked it
up the un
voted a u.n commission voted to remove
cannabis for medicinal purposes
from a category of the most dangerous
drugs
which could clear the way to expand
research and medical use
they're based in vienna and include 53
member states
considered a series of recommendations
from the who
the most important part is removing
cannabis from schedule
4 of the 1961 single convention on
narcotics
experts say this will have no impact at
all on international controls because
governments still have jurisdiction
but many countries look to global
conventions for guidance okay so
this doesn't do anything but it's a
signal from the un
that at this point they believe cannabis
for medical
shouldn't be classified as one of the
most dangerous drugs so this is a very
modest change but
not irrelevant and we should still
support it
all right i need an effective opinion
thank you steph also
um you i've called before on the show on
the basis on
what if the dea could be performed so i
have to ask you a
a dumb question so don't laugh but the
the second question is if i i know got
the opportunity to refer
to ba would you be my practice press
secretary
like on the job with you i would not no
that's not a job i'm interested in
oh sorry well i hope you think it's
better
all right richard from pueblo very very
good an unusual phone call and very uh
strange
audio uh tone there but uh
you know always interested in various
devices that people
sometimes use to call in let's go to um
we want to go next let's go to uh
wait whoa we've got a lot oh how about
flippy from
indiana flippy from indiana you're on
the air
flippy from indiana please unmute you
are on the air my friend
and last opportunity for flippy from
indiana to unmute and talk to me
hi can you hear me yes i can hey david
it's me
um i just was wondering if you've ever
reconsidered making an only fans
sorry if i if i've done making an
omelette what no no making it only fans
you know uh gardening season is over and
it's time for you to show us your
zucchini
that's very clever no listen um i think
i'd i'd be more likely
uh i'd be more likely to show my my
granny smith apples than any zooks to be
perfectly frank flippy
that works too yeah uh no but i am on
cameo which i think is like the work
safe only fans right
well that works well thank you and by
the way where does the name
flippy come from oh just an alias online
oh does it have any meaning no does it
relate to like a
floppy disk for example remember those
five and a quarter inchers
oh it's supposed to be like flippy
floppy like a stupid way to call
flip-flops
oh i got it by the way are you cleaning
a violin in the background
i know it birds sorry oh it's a bird oh
okay
um all right very good well listen i
really i really appreciate the call
flippy
all right thank you have a good day all
right that is a perfect phone call so i
think we're gonna have to end on that
i do apologize i wasn't able to get to
every call
um but we got a wide variety from all
over the world
and we will certainly have to do
something with uh with that
call uh thanks everybody i hope to get
to more calls next time we will take a
quick break
and be right back after this the david
pakman show
at davidpakman.com
[Music]
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly
what one of my favorite apps lets you do
it's called blinkist and what they do is
take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down
into text or audio that you can consume
in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the
important core insights from each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for
if there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blinkist to get
a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
nonfiction book in just
15 minutes i recently read a brief
history of time of course by the great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long and other
things got in the way
and it was fantastic to check it out on
blinkist
blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about
eight bucks a month and you get the
entire library
but you can try it totally free and get
25
off a subscription when you go to
blinkist.com
david pakman i've put the link right
underneath this video
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
all right let's get into audience
questions for the week
one that i've been getting from people
all over the world with anecdotes
and also from americans asking what is
going on elsewhere in the world
is what is the reaction around the world
to donald trump's refusal to accept that
he simply lost his continued
pro promotion of these completely
baseless factless conspiracy theories
about
voter fraud and massive dumps as he
talked about
over the weekend and that he really won
georgia and he really won pennsylvania
and so on
how does the world see it and the answer
is that
much of the world is laughing but a lot
of the world is also
really concerned by by what they are
seeing and of course the question
spot on that it's been a month
there's been no real concession from
trump where he says
i got i got beat i was defeated uh joe
biden got more
votes in more states donald trump has
sort of danced around it
he's authorized the transition to start
and we'll talk about that transition a
little bit later in this segment
he has sort of almost had some verbal
slip ups where he says
you know we won't do a shutdown i don't
know if the next
uh i mean i can't speak for anybody else
but we won't do a shutdown right that
we've seen that stuff and we've even
seen reports of trump privately
understanding that he doesn't have a
path to victory
but there's been no real concession from
donald trump
a lot of the world is laughing and tends
to see trump more as just
an idiot uh and that includes like
anecdotally the people i hear from
who watch the show who are in ireland
just like as one example
they are more on the we can't believe
this idiotic [ __ ]
and the things that he is doing
anecdotally again
our viewers from germany they don't
seem to be finding the humor in it as
much as some others
and they seem genuinely worried about
the state of our democracy now maybe
that's something about
germany's past that informs how the
germans i'm hearing from are reacting
differently to the irish
folks that i'm hearing from but when the
world
sees that world leaders are calling
biden
they're talking about getting things
done with joe biden they're getting
started on a variety of projects and
issues
it's biden that world leaders are now
dealing with when it comes to
coronavirus as an example joe biden's
task force
already uh seemingly more ready and
willing to get things done than the one
that donald trump has had in place for
more than half a year at this point in
time and so
while there is some laughter and some
pointing and some look at that idiot in
the united states
there is also the doubt that the world
is increasingly experiencing about
like what is the standing of the united
states in terms of a democracy
what is going on with the strength of
american checks and balances that this
continues to go on and then
if you're paying attention to the legal
maneuvers that the trump uh
legal team is trying it's the stuff of
shame
not putting in the legal briefs the
things they say publicly
like there was actual fraud they don't
put that in the legal briefs because
they know they don't have the evidence
for it and earlier this week we had this
clip of news anchors from brazil
unable to contain their laughter at
donald trump's bizarre press conference
on thanksgiving day
there's also a lot of straight up
pointing and laughing there's no there's
certainly no shortage of it
we are increasingly seen as an unstable
country
one that cannot be trusted in deals the
iran deal being the perfect example
any foreign deal made with one president
could be thrown out
by the next president as donald trump
did with the iran deal even though iran
didn't actually violate any aspects of
that deal
so this is you know the big picture
is whether you're laughing or crying or
scared or whatever your view is of
what's going on embarrassed for the
united states
the big picture is how can such a rich
country considered to be the leader on
so many issues until only a short time
ago
how can we be having these problems how
can we be having
uh um the the a president
who can't even tell the truth for a
minute when the topic of whether he lost
comes up how do we have so many people
without health care and people on food
stamps and people lacking basic
education and crumbling infrastructure
laughable airports
considered to other rich countries right
like the problems are of course bigger
than donald trump
how do we have this religious not
anti-science
thing running rampant even not just
people
but people in positions of power in the
united states
some of this stuff joe biden can start
to write
uh some of it takes much longer and it's
much more than just a president can do
and it goes well beyond the
the oval office and so we've really got
our work cut out for us
um and and the world is noticing now a
lot of trumpets don't care
a lot of trump is to say why [ __ ]
europeans don't like what we're doing it
must mean we're doing the right thing i
mean that's the approach
that a lot of these trumpists have and
that's part of what we need to fix here
hey david if trump doesn't run in 2024
could tucker carlson be the future of
trumpism and or the republican party
so at this point before i even talk
about tucker
anybody who hears that question and says
tucker carlson fox news propagandist
could never be the republican nominee
seems premature
i am nowhere near as confident as people
saying that
about uh those proclamations look at
2016.
okay who would have thought a few years
prior that trump would be the republican
nominee for you know forget about
president but the republican nominee
so if you say listen it could be tucker
listen it could be don jr listen it
could be
the my pillow guy i would rule nothing
out
at this point because if the republican
electorate has proven anything over the
last four years
it's that they can be bamboozled into
choosing
almost quite literally anyone maybe not
anyone but almost anyone as their
nominee
and they've proven that by how easily
they were bamboozled by donald trump in
2016.
now tucker specifically in 2024
first i think it's too early and the
reason it's too early
is that 2024 is going to likely be more
about coalitions than the individual
so could it be that the coalitions get
behind
tucker sure could it be that the
coalitions get behind
marco rubio maybe could it be that they
get behind
the my pillow guy the the reason i would
rule nothing out is that you have
actual trump cultists right now these
are the people chanting fox news sucks
outside of voting uh vote count uh
locations
these are the people who email me and
they say david don't you realize
trump is getting four more years uh
you've got the trump cultists
you then have the republican loyalists
now i'm i'm kind of
slicing and dicing this a little bit
differently than i often do
often i say you've got the pro-business
people the libertarian people and the
evangelical religious right
this is different because it's more
voting contingencies i'm talking about
trump cultists
republican loyalists in which i include
the social conservatives
the evangelical types etc people who who
are more on cultural
issues uh uh and because of socialism
and so on voting for republicans
and then i've got these kind of economic
conservatives and those are the people
that
that were most likely to not like trump
because they found
all of the other stuff pretty uh
distasteful
um it's it's people who basically want
relatively low regulation
and lower taxes and and business freedom
but they're not social conservatives and
they find trump to be a buffoon
i think that that first group the trump
cultists
mostly disappears unless trump simply
keeps going
and campaigns all through the next four
years and runs
in 2024 to once again be the republican
nominee
if trump doesn't do that i believe that
the trump cultists
are the group that will determine
whether the republican party goes back
to like you know
jeb that type of thing in 2024
or whether trump or someone wacky could
be the nominee
again do the trump cultists
become normal conservative republicans
do the trump cultists fragment and
take away from the republican party by
creating some new coalition
do the trump cult this many of which
were never even paying attention to
politics before trump
do they just get back out of politics
altogether and go back to wherever they
were before
i do think it would be a mistake to say
that
it was only trump's celebrity prior to
2016 that gave him the cult-like
following
the celebrity may well have helped but
what really gave trump the cult-like
following
was that he tapped into these ideas that
were really bolstered during the obama
era
including just standard racism but also
the idea
of working-class whites feeling like
they are losing
privileged status not saying that they
rightly felt that but they felt it
and the sort of xenophobic stuff that
was often kind of scattered
and not above the surface trump was able
to say to all those people
come to the surface say this stuff
publicly you are with me
that's how he developed the cult-like
following the celebrity certainly helped
and so i think those are all factors we
have to think about going into 2024
but i would rule out nothing in terms of
could it be tucker
sure could it be you know ivanka
it could be i would rule nothing out at
this point
david given the fiasco with trump not
conceding
should presidential transitions really
depend
on an administration official of the
sitting president
like emily murphy at the gsa this is a
great question the framework for the
official transition
is outlined by the presidential
transition act of 1963.
and in so far as that outlines
the official piece of the transition
the general service administration head
emily murphy
was um the person who had to authorize
about seven million dollars in funds to
be made available to joe biden to
officially start the transition
now in a sense the transition
doesn't really depend on her and what i
mean by that
is the gsa head as directed by trump
doesn't really need to do anything in
order for
joe biden to be president and sworn in
on january 20th
these are separate processes what the
gsa process
does is it recognizes the current
administration
sees the president-elect as the
president-elect
we are freeing up funding it greases the
wheels for starting to give joe biden
the presidential daily briefing and
facilitating
some some other things but either way on
january 20th
trump stops being president and the
supreme court
chief justice swears in the new
president it doesn't actually depend on
the gsa
that being said i do believe
that at this point in time listen the
the explanation that emily murphy gave
was
um i'm supposed to ascertain the winner
of the election i'm not supposed to
impose the winner on the country and
because it was contested
it was not totally clear to me that i
could ascertain the winner
yet but now i have and she's tried to
kind of pull herself out of this as a
partisan actor
it's basically bs historically
with the exception of the year 2000
where it really did depend on one
recount in one state and it took about a
month
for that to be formally recognized uh
it's pretty clear that there has been
an apparent winner and there was no
reason
whatsoever that emily murphy should not
have done this
earlier and in the 21st century you know
at this point in time
the longest it should really take to
ascertain the winner of an election is a
few days and that's what it took within
a few days it was clear
that joe biden was going to be the next
president so i do
think it would be i mean listen this is
a reminder of what
this reminds us that we have certain
checks and balances in this country that
work okay
as long as you don't have anybody
violating the obvious norms
and donald trump if he did anything is
he went against
all of the norms you know hatch act
sharing classified information all of
these different things
so what we've learned is you could have
someone as whacked as trump
that doesn't abide by the norms and then
you can have a situation where emily
murphy spends almost
a month before formally authorizing the
transition it's sort of a microcosm of
the trump presidency
we probably should have some more
concrete requirements for the gsa right
now again it says
the gsa should ascertain the winner of
the election it doesn't say how
um typically you know the media calls
the race
and that's not official it's not
official until the electors actually
vote
but the gsa goes with it and the process
begins
but there's nothing in the law that
explicitly says that that's how it has
to happen so
i would like to see something made more
explicit
again it wouldn't have prevented biden
from becoming president
he would have anyway but she certainly
was able to gum up
elements of the transition and you could
spell it out much more specifically
that's my thought
the the the important point is the
transition doesn't
actually depend on the current
administration they certainly can get in
the way of some funding for the
transition
but ultimately the presidency would end
and joe biden would become president
regardless on january 20th we've got a
great bonus show for you today
get instant access to the bonus show by
becoming a member
at joinpacman.com
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
hydrant is the delicious fruit drink
powder packed with essential
electrolytes for hydration
and it's more cost effective than
expensive sugary sports drinks
to get 25 percent off go to drink
hydrant.com
pacman and use the code pacman steady md
lets you maintain a meaningful
long lasting relationship with a primary
care physician
who you can meet with anytime over phone
or video chat you don't need insurance
it's only 99 dollars a month with no
other fees or copays visit steadymd.com
pacman to get started blinkist is the
app that helps you become a more
well-rounded person by letting you read
or listen to an
entire non-fiction book in just 15
minutes you can try it for free
and get 25 off a subscription by going
to blinkist.com
david pakman